dori look please all I know is that I
miss them
I really really miss them I didn't even
know what that felt like huh oh my
goodness Nemo are you okay great yes
great idea you take me to find him why
didn't I think of that come on
no if I just take your tag I can take
your place in the transport truck then
you can go back inside to find your
family all you have to do is just give
me that tag
what tag there's a ha there's a tag on
my fin oh no oh I'm okay sorry I suffer
from short-term memory loss you don't
remember what we were talking about
mm-hmm nope not a clue what are we
talking about
Dory's just reached the edge of the reef
she's had a flood of memories she
remembers her family she really wants to
get out there Marlin stopping her and
she suddenly gets very serious and
sincere kind of quiet violins right in
front of her and she says this line to
him was so if you want to give that like
one try not out of breath okay yeah yeah
I'm not to be not out of breath she he's
right there yes Hank's got you in a cup
he's carried you through this whole
exhibit and get you to the top of this
big tank and in this huge tank of fish
your parents are somewhere down in there
and so you're getting a little nervous
it's like being up the threshold of the
house that you grew up and you're like
whoa Oh
like this is really gonna happen so
you're a little excited you're little
anxious I don't even know how long
because while you see I suffer from
short term short term memory loss look
no more talking okay I don't like
talking
I don't like chattering questions and
how are you well I'm fine how are you
I'm fine too news flash
nobody's fine and then my dad was really
friendly and he without your whacky
memories gonna get us caught hey hey I'm
from open ocean open ocean I know where
that is
that's easy but located right next I
don't care you know I think I'm gonna
remember you ah you'll forget me in a
heartbeat kid huh three heartbeats I'll
have a hard time forgetting you though
now you're pushing the stroller you're
moving along any around people you don't
want to be touched you want to put bump
to do it's all kind of enemy territory
so it's kind of a harsh whisper that
you're kind of saying everything with a
little bit of urgency so I'll just give
you this cue here and look and you're
just giving another instruction
okay left all the signs don't perhaps
follow sense open ocean and stir clear
people will yeah especially kids I don't
want to be touched just right can you
please keep it down over there my head
hurts that's my neighbor he was brought
in with a head injury
I know you're talking about me destiny
can't use his echolocation I'm right
here
hear every word you're saying about me
can you please keep it down over there
my head hurts
that's my neighbor Bailey he's brought
in with a head injury I know you're
talking about me dad city location I'm
right here hear every word you're saying
about me now I know there's not a thing
wrong with him now I know you're talking
about me
I really can't echolocate oh I cannot
have this conversation again I hit my
head very hard out there see how swollen
it is nice okay here we go
and wait everybody
hold tight one two
don't move okay This Is It this is it
one two stop on your voice okay this is
where we we're doing stuff we're like he
would be indecisive about these decisive
moments oh you won here we go right
right okay so we could expound on this
if we want right okay um and so this is
her waiting you're you're so you're
looking out your credit peeking through
legs you're seeing a stroller oh yeah
right crossing you're there look out
you're the ones that are gonna say when
it's okay for destiny to jump out of the
water and make a signal so that they
know that they can roll out and go into
the crowd personally okay right it's a
milk it if you want to can you take me
here ah yeah kind of tough for a whale
to travel around here perfect hmm sheesh
its story something's wrong he can't see
you okay tell Dora to go left he says go
left straight straight holy Neptune
she's not alone what what what is it I
can't tell but it's coming for her Oh No
Dory is
sweetie other way okay great
Stewart ten more times yeah can't get
enough of that whale oh well that's
right dear do you think that you could
find me another shell like a shell shell
purple ones that those are my favorite
we will never forget you Dory and we
know you will never forget us there's no
other way now don't know yes it's okay
dear you know not everything in life is
easy isn't that right isn't that right
charlie it's not easy to do I'm sorry I
can't remember right Oh sweetie sweetie
you don't need to be sorry you know what
you need to do you are you looking at me
you just keep swimming I bet you can
remember right honey you just keep
remembering that kid mitt we're just
gonna keep we're gonna sing along where
you sing the song just keep swimming
just keep swimming just keep swimming
just keep swimming just keep swimming
that we can swim along just keep that's
what we're gonna do that's what we're
gonna do we're just gonna keep swimming
yes yes it's awesome you've asked her to
find some shells just found one yeah and
she goes I like shells again UK gonna go
that's right dear yeah you think you
could find me and it's like a little
secret between us and nothing oh you
better know I think I'll sound a little
ok ok looking on mommy
that's great dory you found another one
absolutely go get them kelp cake just
keep swimming swimming swimming what do
we do we swim swim swim swim we swim
just swing
and Men swim it's perfect I'm better
than I thought I only explains why Dory
sings the way she does
you did it kelp cake beautiful exactly
what I needed
exactly Dori Dori stop yelling for a
second it's not a good idea to come to a
new neighborhood and call this much
attention to yourself
you don't understand I remember my
parents names Jenny Charlie Tori Tori
these crabs are locals
I get the feeling they're shushing us
for a reason you might wake up something
dangerous excuse us
hello we're trying to a son son son
these are sea lions
they're natural predators they could
pounce at any moment is there a way to
get us in there that involve swimming
I'm not a bird I swim she flies let's
not mix it no no no no no this is nuts
why do I keep getting talked and go
insane choices now you're flying I'll do
Nemo in the middle and you're trying to
get her to put the lamb okay boo Becky
drop us anywhere now we're okay boo ruh
ruh ruh just wait dad I think she's
looking for a place to live he's
confused Nemo she doesn't even know
which way to look
a little they feel good way
yeah actually if you can switch back to
silhouette in a sec
pull this out so that it's what it's
like to be with her to see this
just so we get the spatial relationship
but I just have a piece of Marlin just
so I feel like he's his eyes would go
from two like long past dad a front on
shot on her face like listening and then
she'd look up and it's like you weren't
looking while you were driving like ride
you want oh my god and then it's just
this coral comes up and you just go poof
through and then you go right to the
wide with the edge of the reef and you
just see her keep you know going with
the debris and just keep when he turns
in the tentacles float they're all just
kind of reacting to the water that's not
that they're he's doing this oh no
because you've been stumping in so I
think it was all into the 3d version
will be just like oh yeah a real soul oh
yeah there's such up put an explosion on
the buck mm-hmm we cut like like because
yeah and you're just it's it's just kind
of a soft open like Italy compared to
what I'm hearing
it either is totally right thing do or
we that's a color but not a stray color
just on being like yeah like on his last
line of yeah you are oh no no that's
nothing I just made like that yeah it's
like a match was develops like you know
just like like a key tree like like it
shimmer yeah ship okay do we go back to
this mm-hmm I go back to the previous
Troy just with one character if you them
actually like as parents trying to reach
through the I mean hopefully not
hopefully lighting wise we won't be
caught up with that all right so final
to fix no and then were cut where's the
seashell well it's here but when where's
the one we cut out here this is Thomas
sets yesterday had questions about just
the value other all this concrete we
want it doesn't regard
the did with that dude with Andrew he
was it was okay what's my there
you